all right this
uh continues the committee of
conference on house bill 187
and uh during the dark hours there
appeared two amendments and i'd like to
call on senator bradley to introduce
all right thank you um so as we
discussed um over the last couple of
days
i made the suggestion that we should
model 187
or whatever the upshot was a discussion
on
house bill 417 417
got non-occurred on there was no
agreement however
that's basically a 417 i apologize i
didn't bring it over
i'm sure but um this mirrors
what is now in hb2
so there's the first is section 8
uh the notification section i believe
that's the same
language and then
9 it allows the
legislature to terminate either a state
of emergency
or a particular emergency order
by a majority vote of both the senate
and the house
um president voting although
constitutionally and i don't recall the
um specific citation in the constitution
but there has to be a forum
and then similar similarly to what was
in
now hb2 for the governor's power to
renew the merchant store is the same so
the language is the same and i think
it will get through the process
let's put it this way without a forum
you wouldn't have a meeting therefore
you couldn't have vote
so i think that that's implicit in what
you said here
well and it's also the constitution
requires a
because that question came up yesterday
at hp2
and we had the governor's attorney in
uh our attorney rick layman and they
just cited the specific reference of the
constitution
yes representative weber thank you
um i'm i'm wondering we have
this is the section that pertains solely
to the commissioner of the
commissioner's orders
so i am wondering why
we have the state of emergency
language in here as well as the
emergency order language
well and i wonder or
like a governor could have multiple
borders under a overall state of
emergency
so that gives the current law right now
says the legislature can override
an emergency but not individual orders
so
if the legislature deemed
one piece of an emergency right
inappropriate
under this language and i just need one
further clarification of what came into
the budget because i
was informed by a wmur last night that
there was
no provision about the governor's powers
of the state of emergency
so what you're saying is this
no way that it's never happened before
we adopt it again
if if you represent to me senator that
about the issue
of without that language
are we giving
the legislature the power to terminate a
state of emergency if they already have
that do they not
and that's what he said at the beginning
was that there is a provision that the
legislature can override an emergency
right but not i mean remember i think
there were some 80 waters issues
right there was not the partial
part of it yeah the line item
my beef with dhhs that got resolved
personally
um was with one particular item
nothing else so i wouldn't want to do an
all or nothing i'm sorry senator gray
when i read this section you know since
the emergency orders can be hung on
a proclamation for the state of
emergency
if you do take away the state of
emergency you've taken away
all of the emergency orders under that
and that's the way i read this
and i had no problem with that but the
legislature doing that
so i'm just i'm just concerned about
putting the removal of the state of
emergency
in this section which deals solely with
the commissioner and whether we are
putting confusion in where confusion
doesn't need to happen
and i wonder if people would consider
saying the legislature may terminate any
emergency order
issued under this rather than the state
of emergency
uh oh we just got a text from the clerk
of the house
what we just
you i'm going to call him get him on the
phone
i i even find that surprising jeremy who
are
discussing because it was internal
version
of the bill your clerk is wrong i i mean
get the speaker to tell them
yes uh the committee and conference
conference would love to speak with the
clerk please
sure the clerk
uh paul smith who are you
you have not spent enough money yet oh
yeah could we go into recess would you
like to hear the clerk no
um i think you folks need to hear the
car i know what it is
i'd like all of us to hear the color
okay please see you
so maybe you can argue your
patience is attempting to stop this
proceeding then
with me okay just a sec let me put it
into my
hearing we're gonna go okay okay
of the dhhs commissioner are we back
yes okay um representative weber
the suggestion that we're making that
will we hope resolve our clerks issue
which was the same thing that i was
speaking about earlier about the state
of emergency being
broader than what the commissioner can
issue
is simply removing the words a state of
emergency
or so that it reads the legislature may
terminate
any emergency order issued under this
chapter by a majority vote
i can see that it's all issued under
this chapter but
if if we take those words out it
eliminates
uh the concern that we are talking about
the governor as well as
the commissioner
to make a difference whether it's any
more and
i put in any because i thought that made
it
but i'm i'm i'm not going to fuss about
the inclusion or exclusion
i like i like the word instead of it
right okay
because so we just strike out the words
a state of emergency
or or or is that acceptable
and i believe the senate is encouraged
house
so that's under consideration are we
so i guess what i do is um
somebody move um senate amendment 203.
could we just go down through one more
time sure that we're all so we're we're
replacing 89
we are eliminating 10. or i guess
maybe we just state that but we're
exceeding to the
receiving from the house position
exceeding to the senate position with
the following amendment
fact 10 is not in but the final version
has to not have the language of 10 in it
however ols decides to phrase that
and then we have already uh agreed to
the senate position
on page nine on the composition of the
uh health and human services oversight
committee
is that you mean the additional member
so that's what we're looking at is to
exceed
to the senate position on this
with the um the amendment two
zero three three which is items eight
nine
a state of emergency for
from line nine we don't actually need a
formal motion
or you know as long as there's two
committees here
okay our committee is in agreement with
the changes that stated
yes
once more for the folks at home
we agree to the we exceed to the
senate version
with the with the changes in
2033 amendment
with the removal online nine of the
words a state of emergency or
that is what we're all agreeing to yes
you